beaucoup pour la voiture
que tu prends en premier
pas très doué pour prendre sa retraite, j'y
travaille
[Musique]
Je vais bientôt me sentir gentil alors j'ai besoin
qu'il renvoie ça à un autre gars pas
toujours le travail du temps je m'en sors tu sais
comment il est sous ça tu connais la
conservation
Comptes fournisseurs comment vous aider
J'aimerais ouvrir un jeu de compte sur l'
attaque terminée la semaine le contrat est devenu
international vous n'avez aucune idée de ce qui s'en
vient
quelqu'un s'il vous plaît donnez à cet homme une arme à feu
jusqu'aux ventes à Manille cool
vous poignardez le diable  dans le dos de lui -
ne devrait pas lieu c'est juste une petite
chose J'ai mis un petit cercle qui
travaille tard donc quiconque vient nos
enfants oh viens casher
j'essaie de faire la même chose
[Musique]